This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个 I-Heart 播客。绝对真人。2%。这是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们在这样一个奇怪的现代世界中，展现精神韧性、保持健康以及建立抗压能力的秘诀。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端蜕变成一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是数字 2。百分比，可在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。在《Look Back at It》播客中。从 1979 年开始，这对我和说都是一个重要时刻。84 年对我来说也很重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利斯。每集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论 80 年代。84 年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you've done.
欢迎在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你收听播客的任何地方订阅《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家最近怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·加姆斯。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都觉得不太安全进行的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的执照专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。而且，仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你必须这么做。
need to listen to learn the hard way on the iha radio app apple podcast or wherever you get your podcast hello and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s the very unprofessional podcast whereby we talk through some of the big changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology chow bonjour how are we all um lockdown week 5 baby just had an extension announced this morning so here we are thriving thank you very much Andrew Barr keeping us safe
你需要在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或任何你听播客的地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。哈喽，欢迎回到《The Psychology of Your 20s》，这是一个非常不专业的播客，我们在节目中探讨 20 多岁时的一些重大改变和过渡，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么。Ciao，Bonjour，大家最近都怎么样，嗯，封城第 5 周，宝贝，今天早上刚宣布延长，所以我们就这样了，感谢安德鲁·巴尔一如既往地保障我们的安全
as always but I hope you guys are all doing well wherever you may be listening lockdown or not hope the sun is shining that you're being COVID safe obviously and that something amazing has happened to you this week
但我希望大家无论在哪里收听，无论是否封城，一切都好，希望阳光灿烂，当然你们也做好了防疫措施，并且本周发生了让你觉得惊叹不已的事情。
I'm just going to jump right into it this topic the friendship breakup has been on my mind, taunting my dreams, quite a bit for the past month or so. But I haven't really been able to work up the courage to record it or research it, I think, for a few reasons. Firstly, it's insanely personal. And although I've talked about, you know, things like unrequited love and hookups and heartbreak on this podcast, this is the first episode where it would just be entirely natural for me to come off looking like the bad guy, which my ego obviously wasn't.
我打算直接切入主题。过去一个月左右，友情破裂这个话题一直在我的脑海中盘旋，甚至在梦中困扰着我。但我想由于种种原因，我一直没能鼓起勇气来录制或研究这个主题。首先，这实在是太私人了。虽然我在这档播客里聊过单相思、一夜情和心碎之类的事情，但这将是第一期节目，在节目中，我以最自然的方式出场，结果却成了坏人，我的自我显然不太喜欢这样。
too fond of. And secondly, I didn't really want to do any injustice or harm to anyone who I was once friends with, who I have quote unquote broken up with, which we're kind of discussed later on. And I think, like, another reason I was kind of hesitant about recording this is it's kind of painful to look back at experiences like that. And I just don't think I was really in the right head space to, like, dig deep into past friendships, which were insanely meaningful for me, but which have now faded, fizzled. We've gone our separate ways. But yeah, I've made peace with all those things.
不太喜欢。其次，我真的不想对任何我曾经的朋友造成不公或伤害，那些我曾经“断交”的人，我们稍后会讨论这一点。我想，我 hesitant 录制这期节目的另一个原因，是回首这样的经历未免有些痛苦。而且我觉得自己当时的心态并不适合深入挖掘那些对曾经的我意义非凡、但现在已经消逝、淡去并分道扬镳的过去友情。不过，是的，我已经和所有这些事情达成和解了。
I talk to my therapist about it. Shout out, Josie. God, love her so much. You're the best. And she said it was a good idea, perhaps even a little bit healing. If I came out with a wise mind, which is her favorite term. So here we are recording in my car yet again, ready to bury some hatches, discuss the psychology behind friendship breakups and the fizzle and why that age old saying is true. You know, if you're not losing friends, you're not growing up.
我和我的治疗师聊过这件事。向乔西致敬。天哪，太爱她了。你最棒了。她说这是一个好主意，甚至可能有点治愈效果。如果我能带着充满智慧的心态来谈论它——这是她最喜欢的词。所以我们又一次在我的车里录音，准备冰释前嫌，探讨友情破裂背后的心理学以及那些渐行渐远的原因，并验证那句老掉牙的话为什么是对的。你知道，如果你没有失去朋友，说明你没有长大。
So strap in for a great episode. I do just want to say before we get into it, this is not some like personal rant about people who have left my life. No bad feelings will be shared here. I just think it's a really interesting topic. And researching this has caused me to reflect on some of my own friendship breakers. cups and I think throughout this episode I was particularly reflecting on three friendships in particular that have all ended in the past year and I just thought there was heaps to learn in this often I think uncharted terrain yeah and I think I just received a lot of personal closure
所以系好安全带，准备收听精彩的一期节目吧。在深入探讨之前，我只想说，这并不是针对那些离开我生活的人的一场个人抱怨。这里不会分享任何负面情绪。我只是觉得这是一个非常有趣的话题。通过研究这个话题，我反思了自己的一些友情破裂。杯，我想在这期节目中，我特别反思了过去一年中结束的三段友情，我觉得在这个往往被认为未知的领域里，有很多东西值得学习，是的，而且我想我从中获得了许多个人的释怀。
looking back at some of those friendships thinking about what I could have done differently or maybe what I didn't need to do you know yeah I'll explain kind of my thinking behind it a little bit later. Yeah, and like I said, a lot of personal closure that I would just love to share. So in researching this episode, I read an article that had probably one of the best titles, and it really, I think, inspired how, where I kind of took this episode, the form that it took. So if you want to read it, its title was Friendship Breakups, the Most Untold Love Story. And isn't that the truth? Isn't that just a big cup of truth? friendship breakups or fizzles, they're just as serious and can create the same feelings and reactions
回首那些友情，思考我本可以做出什么不同的举动，或者也许我根本不需要做什么，是的，我稍后会解释我背后的想法。是的，就像我说的，有很多个人的释怀，我很乐意与大家分享。因此，在研究这期节目时，我读到了一篇文章，它的标题可以说是最棒的标题之一，它确实启发了我这期节目的走向和形式。如果你想读读看，它的标题是《友情破裂：最不为人知的情爱故事》。难道不是吗？难道这不是满满的干货和真相吗？友情破裂或渐行渐远，它们同样严重，并且会产生相同的感受和反应
as normal breakups. You know, the loneliness, guilt, anger, awkwardness, the grief. Like, grief can be a huge component that I think is often underappreciated and not really too often spoken about. And I think friendships also contain just as much love as romantic relationships can and appreciation as well, if you do them right, of course, and heaps of studies have proven time and time again that friendships are one of the most important ways to enrich your life. They improve your well-being. They aid in the stable release of dopamine and serotonin. And they can help you, you know, cope with trauma, cope with things like your parents. I think friendships are just as important as a part of your social network as a relationship is. So I think that, yeah, they're just as important, but they
就像正常的失恋一样。你知道，孤独、内疚、愤怒、尴尬、悲伤。悲伤可能是一个巨大的组成部分，我认为它经常被低估，而且不经常被谈论。而且我认为，如果处理得当的话，友情中同样包含着与浪漫关系一样多的爱和感激，而且无数的研究一次又一次地证明，友情是丰富你生活的最重要途径之一。它们能改善你的幸福感。它们有助于多巴胺和血清素的稳定释放。它们还能帮你应付创伤，应付诸如父母之类的事情。我认为在你的社交网络中，友情和恋爱关系一样重要。所以我觉得，是的，它们同样重要，但它们
aren't always held to the same esteem. And I think this all has to do with how our society creates like an internal hierarchy within our minds of which relationships are more important and thus the level of emotions we're able to feel in those relationships and in response to them. So bear with me here. But in this hierarchy, friendships are not given nearly as much of importance, I think, as familial or intimate relationships. So, you know, friends are just seen as more plentiful and replaceable, which I think is entirely incorrect. You know, good friendships, stable friendships and lasting friendships are incredibly, incredibly rare. But we have been conditioned to place more emphasis on finding and keeping intimate partners. And there's a greater expectation
并不总是受到同等程度的重视。我认为这与我们社会如何在内心中建立一个等级制度有关，即哪种关系更重要，从而决定了我们在这些关系中以及对这些关系所能感受到的情绪水平。所以请大家包容我一下。但在这种等级制度中，人们认为友情的重要性远不如家庭或亲密关系。所以，朋友往往被认为更丰富且可替代，我认为这完全是错误的。优质的友情、稳定的友情以及持久的友情是非常、非常罕见的。但我们已经被灌输了一种观念，即把寻找和保持亲密伴侣放在更重要的位置。而且人们普遍期望
of suffering and grief when romantic relationships end, whereas that kind of reaction over friendships I don't think is as normalized or expected, which is a huge problem as to why we don't really talk about what it kind of feels like to go through a painful end with a friend. I think people often underestimate what a big deal it is for a friendship to end. And they can just be, you know, these breakups of sorts can be just as uncomfortable and sad as romantic endings. You know, I don't really want to stress this point,
在恋爱关系结束时会有更多的痛苦和悲伤，而对于友情带来的那种反应，我认为并没有得到那么多的正常化或期待，这是一个巨大的问题，也是为什么我们没有真正谈论经历与朋友痛苦的分道扬镳是什么感觉的原因。我认为人们经常低估友情的结束是一件多大的事。并且，这些类型的分手可以像浪漫关系的结束一样让人感到不舒服和悲伤。你知道，我其实不想过分强调这一点，
but I just think it's so important. Like you can share a similar level of intimacy, memories, vulnerability with someone you will never romantic or sexual with. And when those relationships come to an end, there is an emptiness in their place because no one is entirely replaceable. And every individual brings something entirely different to your life, even if that friendship is no longer fruitful or successful. I had this actually with someone, like thinking of them. I had this for someone at the end of last year. And I think as much as it was important to no longer speak to this friend and essentially cut them off, there are times that I really miss them and I miss their presence because we did share a lot of memories and a lot of personal vulnerability.
但我只是觉得它太重要了。你可以和一个永远不会发展成浪漫或性关系的人分享相似水平的亲密感、回忆和脆弱感。当这些关系走到尽头时，它们的位置会出现一片空白，因为没有人是完全可替代的。而且每个人都会为你的生活带来完全不同的东西，即使这段友情已经不再硕果累累或走向成功。我实际上在去年年底对某个人有过这样的经历。我想，虽然不再和这位朋友说话并基本上切断联系很重要，但有时我真的很想念他们，也想念他们的存在，因为我们确实分享了许多回忆和许多个人的脆弱感。
So it was a hard conundrum. And I have had quite a few moments, I won't lie, where I've wanted to reach out, where I've wanted to message them, rekindle the conversation, talk it kind of about what went wrong. But I just realized that it is for the best that we're no longer in. each other's lives. And as far as I can see, they're really happy and so am I. So I think it's just best to leave it be, even though it's really fucking awkward when I run into them in Dix and Woolies. Yeah, maybe if they're listening to this, they'll know it's about them. But yeah, I think no one's entirely replaceable, even when you do know that those friendships aren't meant to last.
所以这是一个艰难的难题。我得承认，我有好几次都想联系他们，想给他们发信息，重新燃起对话，谈谈究竟哪里出了问题。但我只是意识到，我们不再处于同一个阶段，这对彼此来说才是最好的。据我所见，他们过得真的很开心，我也是。所以我想最好还是顺其自然，尽管在 Dix 和 Woolies 偶遇时真的他妈的好尴尬。是的，也许如果他们在听这个，就会知道这说的是他们。不过，是的，我认为没有人是完全可替代的，即使你知道那些友情注定无法长久。
And like I said, as important as friendships are, romantic relationships tend to get all the glory. Meanwhile, the platonic ones, they're really undervalued, I think. And I read an excellent chapter of this book. It's called The Friendship Fix. We'd definitely recommend it if you're into this kind of literature. And it's written by this psychologist. Her name is Dr. Andrea Bonner. And this is what she kind of explains. Because there is not the weighty expectation of monogamy, which is often associated with romantic relationships, people have a much harder time ending friendships. So this was a bit confusing when I first read it. And I did think it was like a bit of a stretch, but this is how she explains it and it makes a lot more sense when you read more of
就像我说的，尽管友情很重要，但恋爱关系往往抢尽了风头。与此同时，我认为柏拉图式的友情却被严重低估了。我读了这本书里精彩的一章。它叫《友情修复》（The Friendship Fix）。如果你喜欢这种类型的文学，我们绝对会推荐它。它是这位心理学家写的。她的名字叫安德丽亚·邦纳博士（Dr. Andrea Bonner）。这就是她所解释的。因为没有通常与恋爱关系相关的沉重的一夫一妻制期望，人们在结束友情时要困难得多。所以当我第一次读到这里时，我有点困惑。我确实觉得这有点牵强，但这就是她的解释，当你读到更多内容时，它就更有意义了。
the book. So when you're in a relationship with someone and you're on a, you're in a monogamous relationship, a closed relationship, you have to break up with a partner in order to move on to someone new. So you, you know, you have to break up with them. It's an action that has to happen for you to move on to a new relationship. But in terms of a friendship, there is absolutely nothing stopping you from avoiding a friendship breakup indefinitely, putting off the confrontation and just hanging out with other people instead. You know, you can't cheat on your friends the way that you could cheat on a partner. And you can have multiple friends, whereas in relationships, we have that expectation of monogamy. So often what happens is we
书的内容。因此，当你和某人处于一段恋爱关系中，并且处于一夫一妻制的封闭关系中时，你必须和伴侣分手才能继续寻找新的人。所以你必须跟他们分手。这是一个必须发生的操作，你才能开启一段新恋情。但就友情而言，没有任何东西能阻止你无限期地回避友情分手的对话，推迟正面的冲突，转而和别的人一起玩。你知道，你不能像背叛伴侣那样去背叛朋友。你可以有很多朋友，而在恋爱关系中，我们对一夫一妻制有着那种期望。所以通常发生的情况是，我们
end up staying in these friendships and prolonging them with, you know, little snippets of interactions when we should just be cutting ties. I think also unlike our romantic relationships, or, you know, however unlike our romantic relationships, in which there is kind of an understanding that things may not work out, and that's kind of part of the agreement you both sign up for, you know, the inevitability of a breakup from a relationship in your teenage years or, you know, in your 20s. It's understood. It's a dynamic of a romantic attachment.
最终还是留在了这些友情中，靠着零星的互动勉强维持，而本该在这个时候就彻底斩断联系。我认为，我们的友情也不同于恋爱关系，或者无论我们的恋爱关系有多么不同，在恋爱关系中有一种共识，即事情可能不会成功，这可以说是你们双方都默认接受的协议的一部分，你知道，在十几岁或二十多岁时，恋情分手的不可避免性。这是心照不宣的。它是浪漫依恋的一种动态。
But with friendships, we assume that our friends will be around forever. We expect that we'll be, you know, old people retiring together, beat each other's weddings, meet the family, meet each other's kids. So this means that if there is a breakup, we aren't just grieving the present loss of that friend, but also the loss of that friend in our imagined future. It also makes ending of friendships quite awkward and appears, unnecessary. You know, why do we need to break up with a friend? Why not just let it fizzle and let the debris settle? I think sometimes that's just not really a healthy option. Sometimes it's also
但对于友情，我们总是理所当然地认为朋友会永远陪伴在我们身边。我们期待着我们老去时能一起退休，参加彼此的婚礼，见双方的家长，见彼此的孩子。这意味着如果友情破裂，我们不仅在为当前失去这个朋友而感到悲伤，也是在为我们想象中未来里失去这个朋友而感到悲伤。这也使得友情的结束变得相当尴尬和显得多余。你知道，为什么我们需要跟一个朋友正式分道扬镳呢？为什么不让它自然消散，让尘埃落定呢？我想有时这并不是一个健康的选择。有时它也不是
not the best way to avoid hurt. Like the last taste of your friendship should not be one of bitterness and resentment. So sometimes you do need to have that chat with them. You do need to talk to them and be like, this isn't really working. The same book I was reading, kind of grows into this a little bit more and it concluded that there were two main reasons why friendships end but I think I've added a third because I think it also deserves acknowledgement that's the fizzle so these are the three reasons the three big fat reasons why this psychologist believes that friendships end so number one something bad happens a betrayal circumstances that make you realize that you and that other person can no longer be friends. These are relationships that
避免伤害的最佳方式。就像你们友谊的最后味道不应该充满苦涩和怨恨一样。所以有时你确实需要和他们谈谈。你确实需要和他们谈谈，然后说：“这样真的行不通。”我读的同一本书对这一点进行了更多延伸，它得出结论认为，友情结束主要有两个原因，但我认为我添加了第三个原因，因为我觉得它也值得认可，那就是“自然消散”。所以这就是这三个原因，这位心理学家认为友情结束的三个重大原因：第一，发生了不好的事情——背叛、各种境况让你意识到你和那个人再也无法做朋友了。这些关系之所以结束，是因为
end because of something really terrible, often resulting in maybe a big fight or something of that genre. It's not repairable. The fizzle. You just lose your chemistry with someone. You drift. That's that. No harm. No foul. No falling out. You have those friends you were really close to at some point. and now the conversation no longer flows in the same manner, and you both kind of recognise that you don't really have that same spark. And finally, incompatibility and values. Perhaps you were really good friends for some time, but as you've grown, your compatibility and values in life have changed,
发生了非常糟糕的事情，通常可能会导致一场大吵或类似性质的事件。这是无法修复的。自然消散。你只是对某个人失去了化学反应。你们渐行渐远。事情就是这样。没有恶意。没有伤害。没有闹翻。你会有那些曾经非常亲密的朋友，而现在对话不再像以前那样流畅，你们俩都有点意识到你们已经没有了那种火花。最后，价值观不合。也许你们在一段时间里是非常好的朋友，但随着你们的长大，你们在生活中的契合度和价值观发生了改变，
or maybe your values really never aligned in the first place, and something has made you realize that, or just made you realize that you expect different things from each other as friends. and I think in general this is the most common reason. Friendships typically come to an end because there is a disconnect that one or both of you feel is beyond repair. It's not nasty, it's not a negative thing, you're simply going through different life transitions
或者也许你们的价值观从一开始就根本不一致，而某些事情让你意识到了这一点，或者只是让你意识到你们作为朋友对彼此有着不同的期望。而且我认为总的来说，这是最常见的原因。友情的结束通常是因为你们一方或双方觉得彼此之间存在无法修复的脱节。这并不是恶意的，也不是一件消极的事情，你们只是在经历不同的人生转折，
that are going to take you to different places. And there's that age-old wisdom. My friend Lucy, she said this to me the other day. People come into your life for a reason, a season or a lifetime. And that applies to friendships, I think, more than any other kind of relationship. Think about all those people that you know from high school who are still friends with the exact same people.
这些转折会把你们带向不同的地方。正如那句老掉牙的至理名言所说。我的朋友露西前几天对我说过这句话。人来到你的生命中，都有其原因、期限或伴随一生。我认为，这句话应用于友情比任何其他关系都要贴切。想想所有那些你认识的高中同学，他们直到现在依然和完全相同的人做朋友。
There just has to be, I think, some tension and incompatibility in these situations. You know, how can you be on the same trajectory as every person in your life that you have ever shared a friendship with? People change. And stagnation is really. unhealthy. It doesn't allow your brain to move, grow, change, and it doesn't give you new experiences or new ways to learn with new people. Because if you're keeping all those people that you've always been friends with, there's no room for new people. There's no room for someone else. And that kind of
在这些情况下，我认为必须存在一些紧张感和不相容性。你知道，你怎么可能与你生命中分享过友情的所有人保持在同一轨迹上呢？人是会变的。而停滞不前真的很不健康。它不允许你的大脑移动、成长、改变，它也不会带给你新的体验或与新人一起学习的新方式。因为如果你留着所有那些你一直以来的朋友，就没有给新人留出空间。就没有给其他人留出空间。这就意味着
means it's necessary to shed old relationships to grow into your new skin. Like I said, imagine if you were friends with every person that you have ever shared a connection with. Like, it would be a fucking full-time job and more to stay in contact with all of them, to hear about, you know, provide support to all of them, to have to stay up to date with their lives. Essentially, I think, although that was a bit of a rant, what I'm trying to kind of communicate is that friendships ending is not only normal, but also a necessary part of growth. And it should be something that we are more honest about.
为了适应新的自我，抛弃旧的关系是必要的。就像我说的，想象一下，如果你和每一个与你有过连接的人都保持着朋友关系。那将是一份全职工作，甚至还要付出更多精力去与他们所有人保持联系，去听取他们的心声、为他们所有人提供支持，去了解他们生活的最新动态。本质上，我觉得，虽然刚才有点像在发牢骚，但我想传达的是，友情的结束不仅是正常的，而且是成长的必要部分。我们应该对此更加坦诚。
If you and a person are no longer compatible, you have different priorities. You know, why force it at that stage? Would it not just be better to give each other the freedom to move on and transform into the new versions of yourselves rather than you both kind of having to appease those who are now a reflection of a past you? I think there is one element of friendship breaksups that I do really want to touch on though because I'm very, not, I don't want to say like I'm a pro-frenship breakup person,
如果你和一个人不再相容，你们有不同的优先事项。你知道，为什么还要在那个阶段强求呢？与其让你们两个人都去迁就那些现在只能折射出过去自己的彼此，不如给彼此自由去继续前行并蜕变成新版本的自己，难道不是更好吗？不过，我觉得友情破裂中确实有一个元素是我很想触及的，因为我非常——不，我不想说我是一个支持友情破裂的人，
but I'm pro cultivating the right relationships for you. we often hear someone referred to an ex-friend as toxic or they bring negative energy into their life and I'm sure we've all used that word or you know they're toxic as fuck or their relationship was like so was like really toxic like they're a toxic person and I kind of have always had a bit of a problem with this like do toxic people really exist is this a reason to kind of justify ending a friendship with someone that they're toxic they're inherently toxic And I do have a particular opinion about this, obviously, that I don't think is necessarily shared by everyone.
但我支持为你培养合适的关系。我们经常听到有人把前朋友称为“有毒”，或者说他们给自己的生活带来了负面能量，我确信我们都用过这个词，或者你知道“他们太毒了”或者“这段关系真的很毒——就像他们是个毒瘤一样”。对于这一点，我一直有点看法——有毒的人真的存在吗？这真的是以他们有毒为由去合理化结束一段友情的理由吗？他们本质上就是有毒的。
But I really don't think that toxic people as a category exist. I don't think that anyone in particular is just toxic to their core. People just have friction with other people and not with others. And that creates negativity and that toxicity that we associate with someone in particular. it's not that person, it's your relationship within, with that person, not them. And I think those are some, those things that we can't really confuse. And because of your relationship and because it's not compatible, that's what creates that negativity. Like, no one is toxic.
对此我显然有我独特的看法，而且这个看法并不一定被所有人认同。但我真的认为“有毒的人”这种分类是不存在的。我不认为任何人骨子里就是有毒的。人们只是与某些人产生摩擦，而与其他人不会。这就产生了我们与特定某个人联系在一起的负面情绪和那种毒性。错的不是那个人，而是你和那个人之间的关系，而不是他们本身。我认为这些是不能被混淆的。正因为这段关系及其不兼容，才催生了这种负面情绪。就像，没有人是有毒的。
I like hate that phrase. I don't think that we can claim anyone is toxic. But with that in mind, I do think there obviously is a certain point where friendships do, cross boundaries and become an increasingly negative force on your life. And psychological research does say there are certain personality types that do tend to conflict with others, meaning that those relationships are more likely to be kind of charged with negativity. So these types of people have, like I said, distinct personalities or ways of operating socially, but this doesn't make them entirely toxic or toxic for everyone. They just might not. Be the most compatible with you,
我讨厌那个词。我不认为我们可以断定任何人是有毒的。但话虽如此，我认为显然在某种程度上，友情确实会越界，并对你的生活变成一种日益增强的负面力量。心理学研究确实表明，某些人格类型确实倾向于与他人冲突，这意味着这些关系更有可能充满负面情绪。这些人具有我刚才提到的独特人格或社交运作方式，但这并不意味着他们完全有毒，或者对每个人都有毒。他们可能只是
or with the majority of people. So according to some of this recent research that I stumbled across, and this was really interesting because I'd never heard of this concept before. But this research suggests that there are at least four basic types of people that we generally may see as toxic. So the narcissistic aggressive person, the frenemy, the negative complaining person,
与你，或者与大多数人并不是最相容的。因此，根据我偶然发现的一些最新研究，这真的非常有趣，因为我以前从未听说过这个概念。但这项研究表明，至少有四种基本类型的人，我们通常可能会将他们视为“有毒”的人：水仙花式攻击型人格、塑料姐妹花（frenemy）、负面抱怨型人格，
and the seductive, Dramatic person. Starting off. So the narcissistic aggressive type is often someone who is selfish but still highly charming. So they charm and suck you in and can be rather assertive but they're also inclined towards possessiveness. So although the initial stages of the friendship may be very gooey and exciting, pleasant even, there is often a degree of rage or anger when things don't go their own way and intense
以及诱惑且戏剧化的人格。首先。水仙花式攻击型（自恋攻击型）通常是自私但极具魅力的人。他们用魅力吸引你，可能相当自信，但也倾向于占有欲强。因此，尽管友情的初期可能非常甜蜜、令人兴奋甚至愉快，但当事情不如他们所愿时，往往会出现某种程度的狂怒或愤怒，当你和别人在一起时甚至会爆发强烈的
outbursts almost when you spend time with people or you or they tend to or you know they might perceive that you're neglecting them so the frenemy is the next archetype so they seem like a friend but can often become jealous perhaps they're prone to gossip and you feel like you just can't trust them you might even feel inclined to say that they're or perhaps see that they're deliberately trying to sabotage your happiness amongst other people in order to kind of bolster their self-worth self-esteem as well. And by sabotaging those other relationships, it also increases your reliance on them. So the third archetype. This is the negative complaining person. And this is someone who never, never appears happy. They're never satisfied with your friendship and what you have
情绪，或者他们往往会或者你知道他们可能会觉得你在忽视他们。所以下一个原型是“塑料姐妹花”（frenemy）：他们看起来像个朋友，但往往会嫉妒，也许他们容易八卦，让你觉得根本无法信任他们。你甚至可能会倾向于说他们，或者或许会发现他们为了提升自己的自尊心，正在故意密谋破坏你与其他人的快乐。通过破坏这些其他关系，它也增加了你对他们的依赖。那么第三个原型。这就是负面抱怨型的人。这种人从来、从来没有表现出快乐的样子。他们对你的友谊以及你以任何方式给予他们的东西从不满意。没有什么能取悦他们。我曾有过一个这样的朋友，天哪，这简直让人筋疲力尽。和一个认为自己的人生糟糕透顶、
to give them in any way. Nothing pleases them. And I had a friend like this and my fucking God, it was exhausting. Being around, you know, someone who regards their life as terrible. and can never take encouragement is exhausting. It's so tiring. It makes you feel depressed. You just feel so hopeless. And you want to help them, but it's just sometimes there's just these people who are just ultimately pessimistic. And perhaps at first, you know, like other archetypes, they appear really friendly and they're open to adventure. But it can often change into passive aggression, a need to dominate your social life and a pattern of negativity that is really difficult to deal with. and it's difficult to overcome.
且永远无法接受鼓励的人呆在一起，真的太累了。太让人疲惫了。它会让你感到沮丧。你会觉得那么绝望。你想帮他们，但有时就是有些人，他们最终是彻底的悲观主义者。也许一开始，你知道，就像其他原型一样，他们表现得非常友好，乐于冒险。但这往往会演变成被动攻击、对你社交生活的控制欲，以及一种极难应对的负面模式。而且它很难克服。
And it's, I think, a big indicator of this type of person, the negative complaining person, is that it's emotionally draining to be around them. And it's emotionally draining to hear how everyone and everything in life is failing them and going poorly whilst you're there, you know, trying to hold them up, trying to support them. Finally, the seductive, overly dramatic person. So these people, they're often the life of the party, they're physically attractive, intelligent, charming, exciting, but they steamroll you. They require all of your attention. This is the type of person or individual who never seems to be listening when you're telling them
我认为，这类人（负面抱怨型的人）的一个巨大标志是，和他们呆在一起会在情感上榨干你。当你在那里试图支撑他们、支持他们的时候，听到每个人和生活中的一切是如何让他们失望、诸事不顺，这在情感上实在太耗人心力了。最后，诱惑且过度戏剧化的人。这些人往往是派对的灵魂人物，他们外表有吸引力、聪明、迷人、令人兴奋，但他们会碾压你。他们需要你所有的注意力。这种类型的人或个人，在你向他们倾诉时似乎从来不在听，
your issues or they'll interrupt in trying to make something funny or about them. Just cut you off. They talk over you and they often require a lot of attention and energy but almost never seem to come through for you or they never really seem to acknowledge you either. You're just kind of an accessory for them. They crave attention, but it can leave you as the friend feeling pretty depleted and unworthy, unseen or useless. So knowing that there are these types of people out there, I'm sure we can all conjure upon some image of someone who would fit into at least one of these four categories. But then there's the question, we all know someone like this. So why do we continue to remain friends with people who treat us poorly or who make us feel unappreciated.
你的问题或者他们会打断你，试图把事情变得滑稽或者跟他们有关。直接打断你。他们说话时压过你，他们往往需要大量的注意力和能量，但几乎从来不在你需要时给予支持，或者他们也从来不真正认可你。你对他们来说只是一种配饰。他们渴望关注，但这会让你作为朋友感到精疲力竭、毫无价值、不被看见或毫无用处。既然知道有这些类型的人存在，我确信我们所有人都能在脑海中浮现出至少符合这四类中某一类的人的形象。但随之而来的问题是，我们都知道这样的人。那么，为什么我们还要继续和那些对待我们糟糕、让我们觉得不被感激的人做朋友呢？
So one reason why we remain friends with people a lot longer than necessary is fear. It's fear of loneliness. Humans have a natural drive to avoid loneliness. It's built into our DNA. So when we feel less socially connected or separated or feel like a member of our extended tribe essentially is treating us poorly or withdrawing, it creates this visceral knee-jerk reaction emotionally. And as a tribal species, our brains have adapted to rely on social connections as a means to survive. So according to this neuroscience, scientist, his name was John Kachiopo.
我们与某些人维持友谊的时间比必要的时间长得多的原因之一是恐惧。对孤独的恐惧。人类有着避免孤独的自然驱动力。它刻在我们的DNA里。因此，当我们感到社交连接变少、被孤立，或者觉得我们拓展部落中的某个成员本质上在恶劣对待我们或疏远我们时，它会在情感上引发这种本能的膝跳反射。作为一种群居物种，我们的大脑已经适应了将社会联系作为生存手段的进化结果。根据这位神经科学家的说法，他的名字叫约翰·卡西奥波（John Cacioppo）。
Kachiopo? John Kachiopo. I'll put it in the show notes. You can have a look at it if you want. he's made a career out of basically just studying loneliness a really kind of a sad niche and in one of his recent papers he made this point so the absence of social connection triggers the same primal alarm bells as hunger thirst and physical pain so this is what leads us to maintain friendships even when they are incompatible or we no longer feel satisfied especially if we feel like we have limited options beyond that friend or group of friends. Additionally, unhealthy friendships can do enormous damage to your confidence levels without you even realizing it. So the idea of leaving what is comfortable, even if it's not fulfilling and going out to find you friends, it can be extra terrifying if you
卡西奥波？约翰·卡西奥波。我会把它放在节目简介里。如果你想的话可以看看。他把研究孤独当作了自己的职业生涯——一个非常凄凉的细分领域。在他最近的一篇论文中，他提出了这样一个观点：社会联系的缺失会引发与饥饿、口渴和身体疼痛相同的原始警报。这就是为什么我们会维持友谊，即使它们不兼容或者我们不再感到满足，特别是当我们觉得除了那个朋友或那个朋友圈之外，我们的选择非常有限时。此外，不健康的友谊会在你甚至没有意识到的时候对你的自信心造成巨大损害。因此，离开舒适区的想法——即使它并不令人满足，还要出去找新朋友——如果你
already are in a place of depleted self-esteem. This also kind of leads on to another reason why we stay friends with people who might not necessarily be the best fit for our character or bring out the best aspects of who we are. We want to feel needed. Everyone wants to feel like they provide value to the world. And if we're there for our friends, if we have friends, it makes us feel like we're valuable. And social connections are also an incredibly meaningful and often understated way in which we feel we have purpose, friendships and social ties. They allow us to situate ourselves in our external world, and internally they make us feel secure and supported,
本就处于自尊心耗尽的状态，可能会格外可怕。这也引出了另一个原因，即为什么我们会继续和那些可能不一定最符合我们性格或无法激发我们最好一面的性格的人做朋友。我们想要被需要。每个人都希望自己能为世界提供价值。如果我们为了朋友而在那里，如果我们拥有朋友，这会让我们觉得我们是有价值的。社会联系也是一种非常深刻、往往被低估的方式，通过它我们觉得生活有目标，即友情和社会纽带。它们让我们在外部世界中找到自己的定位，而在内心深处，它们让我们感到安全和被支持，
especially when our presence is serving a function for someone else. The underlying psychology and the socially tuned nature of our brain can also make it exceptionally difficult to end friendships, especially if like in a breakup we're concentrating on times when our friendships were positive and warm and glowy and nice. Friendships have a honeymoon phase just like relationships but I think just like relationships we also tend to outgrow them. Like I said, if you're not losing friends, you're not growing.
特别是当我们的存在为他人发挥着某种功能时。潜在的心理学和我们大脑对社交高度敏感的特质，也会使结束友情变得异常困难，尤其是如果像分手一样，我们专注于友情曾经积极、温暖、美好和温馨的时光。友情就像恋爱一样，也有蜜月期，但我认为就像恋爱一样，我们往往也会超越它们。就像我说的，如果你没有失去朋友，你就没有成长。
But I think the important thing to remember and I know it's just like this isn't like a necessarily very wise thing to say. I just think it's a nice way to end the episode is that friends should be there to support you and to enrich your life. And if they're bringing you down, it's probably time to move on. If you don't enjoy their company, move on. The people you choose to surround yourself with should be great spirits and they should inspire you to be the absolute best you can and just create that energy that you yourself want to embody and represent. I think in our 20s, it's inevitable. You're going to go through a friendship breakup. But recognizing
但我认为重要的一点要记住，我知道这不一定是一句多么充满智慧的话。我只是觉得这是一个结束节目的好方法：朋友应该在那里支持你并丰富你的生活。如果他们让你情绪低落，那可能就是时候前行了。如果你不喜欢他们的陪伴，那就离开。你选择环绕在你身边的人应该充满正能量，他们应该激励你成为绝对最好的自己，并创造出你自己想要具现和代表的那种能量。我认为在我们的二十多岁，这是不可避免的。你一定会经历一次友情破裂。但认识到
when it is time to move on and handling it with grace is kind of our best option at that point. Honestly, I don't know, this is a bit weird, but why not have like a breakup chat about it? I've done it with friends before. It kind of curbs the awkwardness. And obviously that's not an option for everyone if someone's done something really terrible to you. Cut them out. You know, vibe so high, you don't need them. Sometimes, you know, you're just going to have to have awkward run-ins with ex-friends and just hope that you're both mature enough to, like,
什么时候该继续前行并优雅地处理它，可以说是我们当时最好的选择。老实说，我不知道，这听起来有点奇怪，但为什么不就此进行一次分手的对话呢？我以前和朋友这样做过。它在某种程度上抑制了尴尬。显然，如果有人对你做了非常糟糕的事，这对每个人来说都不是一个选项。那就切断联系。你知道，能量拉满，你不需要他们。有时，你知道，你将不得不与前朋友进行尴尬的偶遇，只希望你们都足够成熟，
like not mention it and just ask how each other have been and move on me the bigger person anyhow i hope you guys enjoyed this episode like i kind of mentioned it was incredibly cathartic and it's kind of been building up in my notes archive for a while so i just think it's super important to talk about friendship breakups they're everywhere we can all think of someone who we're no longer friends with maybe we even resent them we haven't forgiven them for something it feels like that friendship felt like a relationship even. So definitely something I think needs to be talked about more. So I hope that kind of understanding some of the psychology behind it was interesting. And like I said, like I always say, I guess, remember to subscribe to this podcast
比如不提这件事，只是问问彼此最近怎么样然后向前看，做那个更大度的人。无论如何，希望你们喜欢这期节目。正如我提到的，这非常具有宣泄意义，而且它在我的备忘录档案里积攒了一段时间，所以我认为谈论友情破裂超级重要。它们无处不在，我们都能想到某个不再是朋友的人，也许我们甚至对他们心存怨恨，因为某事还没有原谅他们。感觉那段友情甚至就像是一段恋爱关系。所以这绝对是一个我认为需要更多讨论的话题。因此，我希望理解其中的一些心理学原理是很有趣的。正如我所说，就像我经常说的那样，如果你喜欢这个播客，记得在任何你听节目的地方订阅，说实话。
if you liked it on wherever you're listening, honestly. I'm sure you can subscribe there unless it's like on the website like my grandparents do it. And I hope that we're all coping well with lockdown and whatever is going on with your life. Yeah, feel free to drop some suggestions as well on Instagram if you've got any ideas about what you want to hear about on the next episode of the show. And as always, thanks so much for listening. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我确信你可以在那里订阅，除非它像我祖父母做的那样是在网站上。我希望大家都能很好地应对封城以及你生活中的各种事情。是的，如果你对下一期节目想听什么内容有什么想法，请随时在 Instagram 上留下一些建议。一如既往，非常感谢大家的收听。2%。这是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T.O.% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中。我将剖析精神韧性、保持健康以及在这个奇怪的现代世界中建立抗压能力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端蜕变成一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即数字 2 的百分比。可在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back at It》播客中。
From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year.
从 1979 年开始，这对我和说都是一个重要时刻。84 年对我来说也很重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利斯。每集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论 80 年代。那真是疯狂的一年。
It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host's Kier Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having him with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor.
那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。欢迎在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你收听播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家最近怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·加姆斯。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都觉得不太安全进行的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的执照专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。
It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。而且，仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你必须这么做，欢迎在 IHard radio App、Apple Podcast 或任何你听播客的地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。这是一个 IHart 播客。绝对真人。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。